the man accused of killing a
four-year-old boy and hiding his body in
a freezer could be facing the death
penalty that's according to a prosecutor
in the case now this comes just less
than a day after 35 year old brandon
toslin faced a judge and gruesome new
details of the injuries the little boy
suffered in court
victoria saha has more
multiple injuries to his small
intestines that's what the court says
were just some of the injuries found on
four-wheeled mason dominguez's body he's
just a baby and
he wasn't protected mary lee ruiz was in
the courtroom as information was
revealed on how her nephew died i would
have
never thought that brandon would be
by far capable of hurting any child the
family dynamic is complicated ruiz used
to date brandon tozlund years ago and
shares two children with him but ruiz is
also the sister of mason's dad eli who
was married to mason's mom
eli died in january of 2021 two months
later her former sister-in-law started
dating tozlund and moved into his house
mason's mom told police she last saw her
son are on december 11 and feared he was
dead according to the lawyer of mason's
mom this is when toastland would start
holding her captive i'm not here to
discredit or
undermine anybody's
victimization but ruiz says her kids
were also there at the same time and
wonders why no red flags were raised i
don't understand how it went so long
and i saw you multiple times what's the
reasoning
for my children
and
my niece and nephew to have to be put in
that type of environment ruiz says for
two months until mason's body was found
in the freezer her kids would tell her
mason was with his maternal grandmother
the kids are
the ones who i feel deep in my heart are
the victims because of their innocence
victoria saha live local now
mason's paternal side will be holding a
celebration of life for him saturday
because they weren't invited to his
funeral now as for brandon he faces 10
charges including murder kidnapping and
child abuse in the death of mason and
then domestic battery against his mother
a hearing in his case on the death
penalty is scheduled for next friday and
his lawyers say toslin plans on pleading
not guilty